président américain il a réuni un sommet
climat en avril avec quarante dirigeants
mondiaux dont la chine le japon le
brésil ou encore l'australie par
visioconférence il les a appelés à
revoir également à la hausse leurs
ambitions
un job hayden est ce qu'il peut prendre
le leadership en la matière sur une
europe parfois frileuses et est divisée
on aurait espéré du continent européen
qui prennent qui prennent le leadership
du débat climatique maintenant on peut
importe finalement qui est le leader du
moment qu'on arrive à suivre les
objectifs de paris et à les renforcer
parce que l'urgence climatique et la
parlement aussi le parlement européen a
aussi décrété l'urgence climatique le
tout c'est que les actes suivent les
politiques suivent et là l'europe n'est
pas leader pourquoi parce qu'il ya
encore deux grandes politiques
européennes qui aujourd'hui ne
respectent pas cette trajectoire vers
les objectifs climatiques c'est la
politique agricole et la politique
commerciale on voit que les politiques
qui sont appliquées aujourd'hui
n'intègre pas les objectifs climatiques
si je prends la politique commerciale
les importations les l'aise
[Musique]